and you see my way alright so this is
all the little people so the first thing
I want to say is Brees line after this
was done what did you say again that
little bag is every shippers dream so
speaking which we should talk about well
what the story is Magic Man comes any
dresses little bag of little people
inside pretty much on Finn's pants er
and he put some sort of spell on pride
to make them look like them would be my
guess you know that's how they represent
them and their friends and stuff Finn
finds and many's already sort of having
like these ideas up Oh would it be like
give BMO and Ice King got together or
something like that or these people got
together and he start has these little
versions of him and his friends and he
just starts messing with them a little
bit just start putting two together
seeing how they get along that different
to with them may bring in the third
person seeing a big fight and he just
kind of becomes God among these people
and he can't understand them he can't
quite connect with them he can just sort
of influence what they do and he becomes
obsessed Jake Lee's for 16 weeks because
that's how long he needs to take to get
over the fact that he's doing this yep
and he comes back and thinks just
obsessed and he he's ruined everything
by interfering too much and so he
finally tries to communicate and he
finds a way by grabbing
and shaking um and yelling at him and he
finally says this is all my fault I'm
sorry and he pretty much puts everything
right at the end and it just you know
it's I'm free pretty much a happy ending
um I don't I love ideas like this I love
the ones like I love The Twilight Zone
where the astronaut finds the little
people I love that Futurama where they
form a civilization on bender and he
becomes guy I love these ideas of how
much should or should the Creator have
influence on their creation if it's not
their creation or he just finds them
it's just a reflection of you wanting to
be God no I am God you should know that
yes I think I've already done like three
stories like where I'm God I think your
critic in the blood stuff but um but no
I really like this idea and but it has
been done a million times so I'm
thinking myself I hope they do something
kind of different with them and I think
they kind of did and I think one of the
reasons this one it's a little different
from others is that I think with games
like The Sims and a lot of these other
things you can play online where you can
become different personalities I think
this is kind of happening with a lot of
people and people either getting too
much into their character or not
realizing the person on the other end as
a person or not realizing the etiquette
all this stuff and and just seeing the
obsession that people get into it I mean
I we've heard stories about this that
people know they just get too much into
their character uh and it is sort of an
extension though because it's also it's
also a little him it's not just he's
playing a character it's kind of little
him and I think like I said I think that
just connects much more than what people
do now with like online RPG yo or like I
said stuff like the stands I mean I I
know there's other examples I just I
don't do those I don't know but no I I
really liked it cuz I like I said I've
seen this kind of stuff where people are
just like oh my reality I'm gonna
retreat to this reality where I can be
this and it so rarely fixes everything
it's like the problems still find a way
to manifest and sometimes grow worse
because now you
or you know actual reality it has fallen
apart and you find you actually just
brought your troubles with you in the
new reality except when you can't
retreat back to the regular reality
because it's like oh I've already
destroyed this so I can stay here but
isn't this supposed to make me happy and
it's it's a whole lot of fun I guess in
terms of watching other oh ok ok I play
this way in terms of like there's a
documentary and I'm I think it's called
second life yes have you seen it ok like
the couple that leave there so a husband
and wife that aren't together that leave
their respective husbands and wives to
get together and of course by the end of
the documentary they're not together
even yeah and they're miserable and
they're trying to blame everything else
for it and it's just yeah cats are
cowboy way there but you you knew going
in that's what's gonna happen and yeah I
love that I love I mean that if you
haven't seen it check it out it's on
Netflix it's very very good and it's
just a fascinating study of all that and
it's not always necessarily it's all bad
it's that if you're thinking this will
fix everything like my problems will go
away with this that's not gonna happen
but most you can do is you can figure
out your problems but you won't
necessarily solve that I've yet to see
it I'm not saying it maybe can in some
way because you know whatever there's
always exceptions but I'm so I've yet to
see it fix a problem for a person I see
it identify I've yet to see it like fix
an emotional problem they've had well
the problem is this in our society yes I
will actually get to the episodes in our
society were so ingrained with religion
and the idea of a God that anytime we're
actually step into those potential shoes
were always knocked down a peg
we're always put on that spot of note
we'll never be able to handle it because
we're doing something else that we
should never be doing kind of like
Frankenstein in Frankenstein's monster
hmm think about it he he created life he
did what you know only God was supposed
to be able to do but obviously not
because he did but in the end eventually
he's not able to control his monster
he's not able to deal with it and all of
that that's where our society is right
now when our societies maybe a little
bit more relaxed with it we will see
enough this sort of some show where
someone does kind of become God and they
are able to handle it and they are being
able to break from their own reality and
deal with it I know numerous I'm on
numerous people that go online and kind
of forget about their past existence and
then kind of come out of it fun oh yeah
I mean anyone that play C's games it's
like they're fine don't get me wrong you
play me a fun that that's fine I know
about the really extreme well of course
but I mean there are people that escape
reality all the time into the video
games into adventure time into whatever
and they come out of it perfectly fine
it's just when we all we ever see in
documentaries or hear about are those
people that go five steps beyond what
the average person would do or even the
kooky person would do these are the
bizarre people I'm just saying it can be
done it's just no one would find that
entertaining you know and even though we
make a little bit of a play for that
Second Life movie I mean most of them
were the extremes but some of them were
fine and some of them were like hey the
world has to adapt to this creation like
the woman with the lawsuit and yeah stop
being Sammy I thought that was brilliant
I thought that was so really the lawyer
it's like well you know binary code is
you know technically like literary text
so you're stealing this woman's creative
you know I mean it's like that is so
clever
um boring stuff like that's boring
though to most people they want to see
the crazies they want to see the kooky
moment but they got them there too I
mean that way but crazy is still the
focus I think they have the sort of
normal I mean as Nobles could be you
know side of it to that hey this is kind
of fun too and here are some neat things
you can do with it and it's got a fun
little escape um plus I also want to see
this most people who play God or God or
whatever has had a long time to do this
Finn was headed for a few days before he
started to lose his mind and started
experimenting a bit too much
let me gotta give him time to get into
the swing of things to become God
well even like even like a kid and
because essentially what he is he's a
kid playing with toys yeah
you Gary it's like yeah well that's kind
of what we're all kind of playing God in
a sense already but what I think is so
clever about this one that's so
different from all those other ones
about God you know they're treating
little people and stuff like that
is that it's a little version of him -
it's a little version of his friends is
what I say they really like that's the
big thing I think separates this from
the other ones it makes it it's
specially fascinating well look like
bender and stuff like that are the
Simpsons where it has the little
civilization growing or yeah oh yeah and
the South Park episode with the sperm
and the seem seem on page yes
ooh scuse me here you're right and I
completely agree they're just another
race in a sense this is little thing
little Jake little Rainicorn they're all
his friends and for even the viewer to
watch it it's like whoa whoa what are
you doing you're tossing you know
rainicorn and fin together that's really
bizarre they don't belong together Jake
and Rainicorn are happy together what's
wrong with you and then you see like
choose goose lollipop girl and
abracadaniel like in a three-way mm-hmm
and turtle princess and it gets really
from I'm having a I like he was the
Goblin King that way around slapping all
the goblins and butts
yeah that's right that's right he knows
us and now he was getting slammed by
that's right unlike you had Marceline
with peppermint Butler and all this
stuff and it was like you're seeing
these things that should not go together
we've already been invested for so many
episodes of this is the way the actus is
the way they are that oh wait no no that
shouldn't be that shouldn't be so as a
viewer you're more invested than these
are people I've only known for maybe
five minutes and I don't really it
doesn't matter as much well and yeah
what I kind of like too is that it is
still like you've at the beginning like
you kind of work Vince coming from -
because you can just relate with just
silly stuff like you know let's just see
what happens if I did this you know I
don't think he really has the hots for
Rainicorn and real life I think it's
more at least nothing into to that that
I'm aware of but yeah
just like Oh see what happens so no
that's why you'll see this happening
over here haha that's funny you know
Marceline would peppermint Butler that
never work you know but it's like it's
just fun to see yeah you know so but
then like when he really gets invested
he suddenly has this responsibility to
it or he feels he has this
responsibility and like I said it's a
very interesting thing that is going on
now that it's not only playing God it's
playing the person being controlled by
God yeah you know and that's why I think
having him also be in there and all
those friends makes it so clever cuz
again with all these online games and
the RPGs that kind stuff is going on
you're both God and you're the person
God's controlling yeah you know very
interesting paradox going on right now
you know and it's I don't know I I
really really like this episode so this
is one of my all-time favorite episodes
of the series
just how like Fitness like oh this is
kind of fun it's one of my favorite
parts when in the beginning he's in the
bed and he pulls out the characters and
he hooks up cupcake with Rainicorn but
before he does that he pops out of the
blanket looks over at Jake like he knows
what he's something is wrong yeah wrong
or at least weird or yeah unnatural and
he goes back in he's like okay and he
doesn't it's like so he knows that
something's a bit off but at the same
time curiosity takes over yeah it's just
too tempting yeah and honestly if I had
like a bag full of my friends and
whatnot have fun with that I mean like
okay let's see what happens if this
happened over here and that did excuse
me this wasn't the same time a less
gassy Jason but yeah Plus at the same
time you let's say you are playing God
you lose track of what some of the
characters you're not going to be able
to keep track of everything that's going
on like you've had Marceline and Butler
peppermint Butler what was wrong with
peppermint Butler he was half gone yeah
Finn has just kind of lost track you
can't keep track of all of them um you
know he's not omnipresent he doesn't see
and know everything that's going on I
remember he even already made the
distinction of the c-listers compared to
the a-listers and it's like you know
he's no
and I think he finally realized that
especially when his own character was
like on the edge ready to die well and I
think it was clever too that they didn't
talk like them they all had the Charlie
Brown and all it's a thing even in their
own point of view you know where Vince
the cloud got or whatever they I thought
that's clever because that still creates
a little bit of a separation like it's
not quite us yeah and I think then maybe
cuz if they were talking like us the
whole time I think we'd all seep in is
just like the biggest most evil person
in the world or something for him doing
all this stuff up because there is that
distinction of the language and it's
it's another filter of understanding
them it makes it a little bit more
understandable other kind of like toys
right or are they I mean they seem to be
happy yet wherever they are they're in a
bag they're not like hey what's going on
here or unconcerned they're just so
going along with whatever so they're in
their own kind of environment I thought
was clever too that you sort of see what
their environment is too that they see
the world very differently you know and
how Finn in the clouds will come you
know yes I keep shaking him and then he
disappears for a second because I'm
sorry my arm got tired so you know I see
stocky still doing this and it's just
yeah make it give the ladies what they
want yeah I made that too easy sorry
I love what they did with what Finn did
first off with him and Flame Princess
move together on that puppy be in
between underneath asleep and then Flame
Princess gets all pissed off and they
get into a fight PB comes out with a
Rainicorn like oh Jesus then a little
bit later on you find out the PB s--
finds food yeah the waves raving PB was
hilarious
it was good I love this episode yeah I
think this is one of my favorites I
think this one's really oh it's a
standalone and it's a great commentary
but it's not it's not too serious like
the ones that have been like you know me
really good points have been
you know heavy on their message aren't
always like soup you know they're
usually pretty serious yeah and they're
not very well but this way is still
light-hearted and clever but not like
man I just feel like my heart's bit torn
out watching that you know it's still
funny it's a clever idea so it's again
it's nice to have something I can just
juggle it and try something new so yeah
I really enjoyed it yeah so this is one
of my I was excited to see this one
because every time I see it I just love
watching it ya know it's uh it's a good
one so I know everyone in the comments
has been talking about this next one is
it good no I don't know many people
talking about this one actually I saw
people talk there like you know Jake's
dad Jake's dad like everybody was going
Jake's dad Jake's dad like that
Jake's dad I don't know what comments
you're reading all right well wah wah
wah wah wah wah wah wah